كل يوم نخسر المئات،
ولهذا السبب نواصل القتال، وهذا هو
سبب استمرارنا في القتال، أتمنى أن أقول إنني قد
أزيل حمل ثقيل عن
كتفي بعد الإدلاء بشهادتي، لكن لا، علينا
مواصلة القتال ومحاسبة هذه
الإدارة.  نحن
متفائلون للغاية، ونعتقد أن الأدلة كانت
دامغة على الحكومة،
ولم تجادل الإدارة حتى في
حقيقة أن هناك إبادة جماعية مستمرة،
يقولون فقط احكموا على كل ما يحدث
سواء كان 20.000 أو 30.000 أو 50.000
أو 200.000 أو 2.2 مليون شخص
قُتلت في النهاية، لا يمكنك فعل أي شيء أيها القاضي، لا
يمكن لأحد أن يفعل أي شيء، فالرئيس يمكنه أن يفعل ما يريده بحق الجحيم
وماذا نقول لذلك،
لا، لقد تم الاستماع إلى المدعين
ورؤيتهم في قاعة محكمة أمريكية
وتم الاستماع إلى الحجج و  أخذ
القاضي وايت على محمل الجد، وقال إن هذه هي
القضية الأكثر صعوبة من الناحية الواقعية والقانونية التي كان عليه أن يتعامل معها على الإطلاق،
إنه لأمر خطير أننا هنا بشأن
الإبادة الجماعية، نحن هنا بشأن
مساعدة الولايات المتحدة وتطهيرها من
الإبادة الجماعية في العالم كله  يطالب
بوقف ذلك، ويطالب العالم كله
بأن تتوقف إسرائيل وأن تتوقف
الولايات المتحدة عن دعمها، والآن هناك
رجل واحد يحكم على وايت يمكنه
تحقيق ذلك، ونأمل أن
تفعلوا الشيء الصحيح